hi i'm ryan i'm a tasty producer and
today we are making pumpkin spice cookie
sandwiches inspired by the lg tasty
cookie kit just in time for the holidays
i am not an experienced baker i am an
amateur if you will when it comes to
baking i mainly
use
pre-mixed brownie boxes and cookie boxes
and so today for this video i'm trying
something a little bit different i'm
going to try and make these cookies from
scratch so thanks to the lg tasty cookie
kit the audience should be able to make
these cookies a lot quicker than i am
able to today
i hosted one thanksgiving besides that
i'm usually meeting up with family or
doing a friends giving and it isn't
until just recently that i've been
bringing something to contribute to the
meal before i was just some punk kid and
just ate whatever was there but now i
have these pumpkin spice cookie
sandwiches and i'm really excited to
contribute them to the next thanksgiving
get together i think baking and cooking
is the most stressful part of the
holidays but i'm definitely feeling less
stressed this year because of the lg
oven i have baked in a few different
ovens before and i've had varying
degrees of success some of them have
burned some of them just were mush and
didn't bake all the way through and so
it's really nice to have this oven
because it's so consistent
one thanksgiving we had a good deal of
pumpkin pies and there was one leftover
one full pie and the next morning i just
ate that entire pie for breakfast so
that sort of speaks to my love for
pumpkin i really love pumpkin i don't
know what it is
my sister introduced me to pumpkin spice
back
in my high school days she was getting a
lot of coffees and getting a lot of
pumpkin spice lattes and
for a while i was that basic boy who
just kept on getting pumpkin spice
lattes
i still am
that's so good
[Music]
[Music]